Okay, so, finding the largest value in a set is something which uses what's called a reduction.
It's a parallel algorithm, and it is in fact a bulk parallel algorithm,
so that is yes. In this case, you're summing repeatedly between threads to find who has the greatest element
and reducing that down to a single element, which is the largest of them all.
This is actually very similar to summing elements of an array.
This is called a parallel reduction, and it's something you've probably seen before
that is also a bulk parallel algorithm that works on the same lines.
Adding two strings together, however, is not a bulk parallel algorithm
because you have to work your way to the end of the first string and then add character by character
the elements of the second string. This is a serial operation,
and so it would not be something that you could do with a large number of threads together,
so it is not bulk parallel algorithm.